给大家分享一下怎么做点小钱吧
就每次分享这个话题的时候
我都很心痛
为什么要讲这这个话题呢
就是因为我真的看到很多人
这两年生活的不太好
有生活的现在困境
而学校又不交
那我就知道一点
我想把这些东西分享给大家
可是每次分享的时候都会有人说
交你赚钱的人都想赚你钱
要不然就是个酒菜的
我前面说的一大段
不是想让你相信我
你相信我跟我一点关系都没有
因为我也不证明的钱
对吧
我之所以说的一段是希望大家不要限制你自己
你错过了很多东西
今天那一种视频有点长
到对我常味不知道
因为我就是随机的
讲究小故事
真是法徒的故事
正好这两天
有一段时间我学偷刺
我记不把
巴胃特末格所有的书
记不巴胃特末格的书
我全都基本上都看过
只要能睡到的我都看过了
那个时候的话才知道
原来有
原来有个
我们大会
我说这个我能大会
它是怎么
咱们大家呢
我就在网上说
结果就受到了一个铁子
这个铁子告诉你
怎么参加工大会
巴胃特的这个公司
到底是什么样的情况
它的利益是一个背景
什么的
它有一段是
让你免费看的
然后本来是说费的
说费多少钱呢
说一块钱
说实话
就他露出那一段
我认为就吃一块钱了
你何况会怕还有很多那种呢
然后就真的花了一块钱
把他买下的
因为这个个酒菜吗
我认为不是
因为他截上我当的时间
好
这是一个例子
然后
讲一下我个人的分散里
我在北达旁厅的时候
就在饭了没得吃
就现在就给人装机器
旁厅嘛
装机器
然后北达有一个三角地
北达同一都知道
有个三角地
上面会踢很多公告
然后就有人踢在网告
说是谁会做这个程序
那如果真的没饭吃了
那个程序我会做
我不会做
但是我看看
我觉得我可以会
你逼都没饭了
恶得不行
然后就找人家了
然后你问说
这个程序你做过程序吗
就是你之前写过那个程序
我没有正面回答
你常常说你这个程序
很简单能搞定
然后我就说这样吧
就是跟我一个礼拜的时间
对吧
如果你能找个别人写的就写了
如果没有的话
那一个礼拜我给你动气
拿着吗
对吧
然后有一个礼拜的时间去
跑定的
最后真的就跑定了
所以你说这个是不是是个骗人呢
你要说骗人
我也我也不否认识
我们有侧面回答
但是结果上来说
结果是没有骗人的
我当时戒游田的项目
其实当然游田项目
有一个数据签一项目
就是
东宇们的很多老伙子
谢谢
你们今天可能知道内部真相了
就是数据签一项目
你各种各样的数据筭
这件的数据来回签一
说实话很多数据筭
就你们使用的数据筭
我都没见过
你要完成签一项的线的局
所以那个软件
我其实是一边学一边做的
差不多一年吧
咱们应该刷了一年的时间
把那个事搞定
你说我做这个软件之前
我会贸我不会
那我是一边学一边做
最后做完结果骗人的吗
好像没有
结果到现在为止
游田还在使用吗
然后我大概是有12年钱吗
06年06年
06年青年
大概17万年前
我那个时候就已经开始使用
神经网络了
当时我们做这个胜游分析
大清的老伙已经应该
应该知道这个事是吧
就做那个到底还剩多少油
当时用了很多的方法
就是神经网络呀
什么的
会吗
不会
现学
就很容易现学
那个时候还去学
几作标
都是一边学一边做一边做
骗人了吗
反正我接这个项目之前
我不会做
我不会的
但是到最后教那个结果
有没有骗人呢
很多人还在使用的
对吧
所以
所以各位
你去思考一下
我反正从这个地方
我能得到一个点
这种就是
好的东西
不是你上来就会的
但是你可以会
就接的时候你认为你可以会
那最后你的交付的结果
是没有骗人的
对吧
人间有价值
就OK了
对吧
正好今天的话
我看了一下
这个三年生活中看
小年生活中看里面
就看当了一片文章
叫选择张普风
有关高考交入的生意
这里边就报告了
张普风
就是
做了个去航舟啊
做了点公司干嘛呢
就是高考资源
天报服务的这么一样公司
毛利潤及高
就是用一万块钱
换一个确定的案
有
一万块钱
你告诉我这条个酒菜吗
但是如果是个酒菜的话
各位
我们家这个名字
刚放出来马上就光了
做得强的
对吧
那为什么没有加上不一圈呢
那我认为你如果你认为
这个个酒菜的话
那我去认为你也可以试试
你也可以去割个酒菜
好不好
而且你个完酒菜以后
人家的家长都说
不错
都很好
对吧
你去找这样的用户也可以
那我为什么讲这一大堆
我告诉大家一个很简单
很简单的
赚钱的方法
现在方法不会
因为大家显他要很多很多的相关的条件
任何一个变量出现问题都很多
都可能会罢掉
但是增加小钱
相对来说是比较容易的
为什么比较容易
因为你基本上
能看到市场上确实
然后去你自己可以搞定
把这个问题搞定
你就可以装到钱了
就不利子
我说思组很简单
找到市场上
人们真正需要什么
就是
我需要什么
我有什么困难
我想知道对的答案
对吧
但是呢
他找不着
还有很难
他不会走
他打下去走
或者是不会走
所以要正乱人的钱
这个很容易的
然后呢
你去找这个答案
就像
八位子的鼓动大会的这个
对吧
你花上两周或者三周
算是找这个答案
然后一说会一块点
真正很用心地给人提供这个绝凡
这个难吗
首先我说第一个问题
就是人们需要什么
人们需要什么
就是人们经常抱怨什么
抱怨最多的
基本上就是需要什么
还有一个
我告诉你这个学校
是什么
这个
媒体不是刚出现的
就是今天人们所谓的问题
很多时候十年前
二年前就赢出去了
对吧
然后答案也有
散落在各个地方
你是完全可以把他们搜集过来的
现在有AI的更方便了
但是不是简单的对情
你真的就认真的去分析
去思考
去找你
跟人家一个
比较有深度的
绝凡
对吧
你把放过来
有没有需要呢
肯定是有人需要的
对
那很难说
我需要有流量啊
对对对
你可以用刚才
团的方式去
拍摄短视音
去鞋文章
来获得流量
能力了吧
那好了
一块钱
然后你在知识图备
不就是不不就猜了吗
这种小钱其实是很容易做的
只要你愿意思考愿意想
这个世界上
蓝人太多了
就一定要学会赚蓝人的钱
对
还有人什么呢
就是他自己不会思考
所以各位你好好思考
想一想
对吧
大外儿不是说了吗
就是
人们有需求
有需求
但是用没有办法获得的
这些东西
都是可以赚钱的
所以刚才那个方法
其实是一个非常好的方法
各位最后再跟大家说一下
就是不要认为别人教你怎么赚钱
他就是个酒菜的
不要认为一讲成功学
就有问题
这边说是成功学
对吧
巴拉巴西成功学
他就是专门研究怎么成功的
你可不是成功学吧
但是成功学了
人家做者都说了
这就是成功学
专门研究怎么成功的
对吧
但是你看看这个做者是
巴拉西
他是谁呢
他是
美国物理学会的运士
是虽压力科学
运的运士
是欧洲科学院的运士
美国东北大学的教授
网络科学研究中心的
创始人和主任
然后认知于哈佛大学
媒体学院医学系
谁给他翻译呢
新南大学
计算机与信息
科学学学院的教授和副院长
还有电子科学大学的教授
两个人给他做的翻译
所以这个是不是成功学的
是成功学
他在跟酒菜吗
好像不是吧
人家就是个物理学家
所以不要议听到成功学
就是怎么样了
一不要一看到
别人教你
叫小先生
他就是个酒菜的
你先来把自己限制了
你自己找了个种子
然后把自己赚进去
自己赚到这个种子
然后在自己的三个数
然后有人说
我帮你解决出来吧
你爸就去找人家
说你不要抢我买的食物